hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe i'm your host sean
carroll
and we're continuing today our journey
back up to the world of our everyday
experience to the macroscopic world of
people
and puppies and planets from the
microscopic world
of fundamental physics quantum field
theory and so forth and today the big
step we're going to take is to admit
that none of us is laplace's demon we
started this series
many videos ago talking about the
clockwork universe and our ability to in
principle predict
exactly what's going to happen in
practice we're not able to do that
so we'll be talking about are the
concepts of probability
and randomness these are ideas that are
both very important in
physics obviously in science more
broadly but mathematicians have a lot to
say and philosophy has a lot to say
as well so there's subtle topics that
we're not going to do complete justice
to but we'll get some of the basics
across
and i want to start let's remind you
first about what the clockwork universe
was the universe that we thought
was there in uh classical mechanics
and one in which in principle newtonian
laplacian mechanics you might want to
call it
giving laplace some credit here because
he's the one who came up with the idea
of laplace's demon
and vast intellect that could know in
principle the position and velocity of
every particle
and from that make predictions both
about the future and retrodictions about
the past
okay so this is a certain viewpoint on
the world
now we know that quantum mechanics is
going to mess this up a little bit but
let's uh
we'll save that for later in this video
but the picture
you remember was you have space
at some time so time is going up
and there's going to be some stuff in
the universe
which is going to evolve you know from
these particles
moving with these velocities to some
other set of particles
moving with different velocities and the
laws of physics get us there and the
relevant law of physics here is simply
f equals m a the force is mass times
acceleration
in other words the mass of the particle
times the second derivative
of its position with respect to time
first derivative is the velocity second
root is the acceleration and the point
is if you have a bunch of particles
interacting through some forces
and you tell me their positions and
their velocities this equation tells you
how the velocity changes instantaneously
over time
so in principle i can use calculus to
chug forward or backward in time and
figure out
what the system is going to do the whole
system if it's a closed system
if i know everything that's going on
inside it so i actually uh so we're
going to talk about deviations from this
viewpoint i mean not that this viewpoint
is uh
wrong in classical mechanics if
classical mechanics were true this would
have been correct
but it's not the whole story because
we're not liposucting we don't know the
positions and velocities of everything
so can we do something
or are we just stuck and being able to
say nothing at all
but before i do that i want to give you
a footnote it's it's bad to start
the video or an essay or a lecture or
anything like that with a footnote that
it's kind of in the side
but in this case i think it's it's kind
of a very important conceptual point
and that point is that even this
newtonian system
classical mechanics is actually not
deterministic
in the way that you might have hoped you
know we've talked about it as if it is
uh it turns out when you get into the
equations a little bit more carefully
you find that this hoped for determinism
isn't quite there it is almost there in
fact technically speaking it is almost
always
there but it's not always there and to
show you that let's give you a counter
example there's a famous counter example
called
norton's dome uh john norton
is a philosopher of science university
pittsburgh he's alive contemporary guy
hi john if you're if you're listening to
this
so he wrote a paper about causality and
he uh suggested this as an example of
when it would be hard to pinpoint the
cause of something happening
and the idea behind norton's dome is
it's just a classical mechanical system
it's in spherical cowl and so there's no
friction there's no air resistance
nothing like that and we are literally
considering a dome
so by which we mean uh some sort of
structure architectural structure okay
in the shape of a dome
and there's a point on top and this dome
has a very specific
shape so if you call the height h i
don't know why he did this but h is the
distance down from the top of the of the
dome there's a specific formula for the
height
uh as a function of r
the distance you are away from the
middle and
h goes as 2 over 3
g r to the three halves
where g is the acceleration due to
gravity so we're just having a dome in
earth's gravity
that's 9.8 meters per second squared for
those of you remember your
high school physics right acceleration
due to gravity
so of course there is a kind of
trajectory for a particle let's put this
in color so you can see it
there are kinds of trajectories for
particles that just sit exactly at the
top
of the dome forever so remember we're
not including
quantum mechanics no quantum
fluctuations we're not including
air resistance or random motions of
molecules were being completely thought
experimenty
and saying that in principle a ball
frictionless could sit exactly at the
top forever
okay no one is surprised by that but
it's unlikely to happen in the real
world it's like trying to balance a
pencil on your desk exactly it's
it's hard to do in the real world it
requires strictly infinite precision
in putting it there which is hard to
achieve in reality
there are also of course trajectories
where the ball rolls down
the hill and what norton showed was that
if you in
with this particular shape of the dome
there's some other shapes that also work
but a typical generic shape would not
work this is one that does
you get the following property that
there are solutions
where the ball literally sits stationary
not moving a little bit
not moving at all okay it's just sitting
there stationary
and then it starts to roll down and this
is happening without any force this is
why he was talking about it in a paper
on causality
nothing started it happening okay
nothing pushed it
it just suddenly starts rolling down
with a certain trajectory as a function
of time
and everywhere including at that moment
when it starts moving it solves newton's
equations
okay it solves the f equals ma equation
you can figure out what the force is
due to gravity on a dome of this size
and
uh the size and shape and what happens
is the reason why it's possible
is because at that point at that point
where it just starts moving
the position is zero r equals zero okay
it's just sitting there at the top
the velocity is zero it hasn't started
moving yet and the acceleration is zero
because there's no force acting on it is
right at the top of the dome
but the third derivative of the position
with respect to time is not zero
in this particular solution that norton
was able to find which means that if you
wait some finite time later the ball
will have moved
and that kind of solution is going to be
a solution
for any moment that the thing starts to
move so
you can tell me that the ball stays
there over time for a certain amount of
time
and then at some moment that you pick
completely arbitrarily
it starts to roll that is a solution to
newton's equations of motion
and furthermore uh there are backward
solutions right the laws of physics are
time reversal and variant so there are
solutions
where the ball rolls up and it slows
down and then it gets to the top and it
stays there forever
okay so in both of these cases you can't
predict the future from the past and so
just to be super duper clear here when
the ball rolls up to the top
and and sits there it doesn't roll up
and go slower and slower and slower it's
not like zeno's paradox that it sort of
gradually gradually asymptotes to the
top
it reaches exactly the top at some
finite time
and then it stays there forever or it
stays there for some time and then rolls
down in a different direction
right all of those are solutions to
newton's equations
and it has to do with the fact that
these equations are non-linear in
particular ways
but the point is that given strictly the
construal
of classical mechanics defined by
newton's equations there is
not perfect determinism in there that's
not quite how the equations work out now
it's obvious from this example or it
should be obvious
that you really do need infinite
precision to set up these initial
conditions the technical term is it's a
set of measure zero
in the initial condition space so it's
never going to happen in
the real world but it could happen in
principle right so that's the
that's the kind of thing that
philosophers and mathematicians care a
lot about
in principle it could happen so you
can't say that even
good old newtonian laplacian physics is
perfectly deterministic in that sense
however having said that i mean i said
that both because it's intrinsically
cool and because you know you should
know what the limitations are when you
say something like newtonian mechanics
is
deterministic i say it all the time
because what you really mean is this
deterministic
up to except for a set of initial
conditions of measure zero okay
but maybe that's maybe that's
interesting maybe the maybe uh
of course we know the newtonian
mechanics is not right quantum mechanics
is right so
the question will be even more
complicated once we get into quantum
mechanics
okay so you could imagine saying well
then even in newtonian mechanics you can
imagine that
things will happen in the future that
cannot be strictly predicted from the
past
and that's true more broadly that we
have situations where you can't predict
exactly what's going to happen
but things like this things like
norton's dome are not the real reason
why
we have that kind of unpredictability in
nature
uh in the real world we have
unpredictability you know when we go
gambling okay we have las vegas behind
me here
uh and this was in fact historically
this played a big role
in the development of the theory of
probability i think that
my understanding is as with many things
in math the initial steps were taken
during the islamic golden age right
arabic and persian
mathematicians worked out some
probability tables a lot more progress
was made
uh in the european enlightenment and the
scientific revolution people like
fermat and pascal were literally worried
about
playing dice and playing cards and
that's how they worked out a lot of the
theory of probability uh our old friend
pierre simone laplace worked out some of
the important issues in probability
actually john von neumann i think i
mentioned i might mention it
appeared on the podcast i did recently
on the mindscape podcast with maria
konicova
where we talked about uh poker and poker
theory
and a lot of game theory as we currently
understand it
was invented by john von neumann because
he wanted to become a better poker
player
so the real world aspects of probability
come up in gambling and in games of
chance and that leads to a mathematical
formalization of it
so we want to understand how you can
have these issues of probability like
you don't know what coin is whether the
coin is going to turn up heads or tails
right
you say the coin has a 50 50 chance of
being heads or tails
there are 52 cards in the deck half of
them are red half of them are black
you say the chance of getting a red card
as the next one flipped over is 50
things like that what does that mean in
a world that in principle is governed by
newtonian mechanics it's not this
right so i mentioned norton's dome as an
example of
the very very delicate but precise ways
in which newtonian physics is not quite
deterministic
but don't leave behind the fact that
mostly it is deterministic
okay like norton's dome and similar kind
of counter examples
are not what's going on to lead to
questions like the coin is 50 50.
what's going on is that we don't know
what the exact
laplacian initial conditions are we do
not know
what the position and velocity of every
molecule in our bodies or in the coin or
in the deck of cards
are so we want to formalize that into a
notion of probability
so oops we're green here sorry
uh so we want to talk about what it
means to be probability and that sort of
has two aspects
one aspect is the sort of the formal
mathematical aspect
how do you define probability and put it
to work but then there is the more
philosophical aspect what do you mean
by probability and both of these i was
going to say both these are complicated
but they're complicated in different
ways the mathematical way
is just it's figured out we basically
know the aspects of probability that
matter in simple cases
there's some definitions etc you have to
remember philosophical underpinnings are
still
under debate actually people disagree
and they disagree in very practical ways
that have consequences for how we do
science so it's worth thinking about
that but
let's do the math first okay let's do
the sort of the mathematical
uh formal aspects we define what we mean
by probability okay so we say that
here's the picture we have in mind we
have a universe
u of possible events so we have a
universe
of events and let's call the events x
y z etc so here are some events
it's just a set this is don't you know
uh
think of this blob as representing
anything particular it's just a
collection of possible things so the
universe might be the universe of
possible
outcomes for tossing a coin might only
have two events in it heads or tails
it might be the universe of possible
cards you can draw from a deck and it
would have 52
different events in it so here's events
x
y etc and then there are um
subsets we can group them
into subsets of events
a b etc and the subsets may or may not
overlap so you know here's a subset a
here's a subset b they overlap
and what we do is we define a measure on
this space
of events so a measure is a way of
assigning sizes to different subsets of
some
bigger set uh so i've already used the
term measure zero when we were talking
about the set of initial conditions that
lead to norton's dome
there's zero measure they exist these
initial conditions but they're of zero
measure you would never hit one randomly
if you were choosing initial conditions
randomly
out of a bag and so we want to define a
probability measure
and the way to do this was formalized by
a mathematician
uh kamalgarov
so we have the commodore of axioms for
probability
and they're actually pretty simple to
state well i'm not you know
there are different levels of complexity
and rigor you can state them at so i'm
going to be a little bit casual here
like when you have
infinitely big or continuous sets of
possible events then things get
complicated but with finite sets
it's pretty straightforward so one axiom
is that the probability of any event
is always greater than or equal to zero
okay the probability measure
is never negative the probability for
something is not negative now
as soon as you say that some
mathematician in the back of the room
starts thinking hmm i wonder if i can
define
probabilities with negative values of
course you can you can define
non-standard versions of probability
the komolga of axioms say probability is
never negative
the total probability so if you add up
over all
x's in the set that you're considering
the probabilities of those x's you will
always equal exactly one
so the probability of something
happening something happening is exactly
one
okay we accept that right that seems
reasonable for a definition of
probability
and finally slightly uh more
non-trivially but
still pretty easy to understand if you
have two subsets
a and b that don't intersect
so that's math notation a intersection b
is the empty set
okay so this is not true for the subsets
i drew here but
you could imagine two subsets that don't
intersect
then the probability of
being in the union of a and b okay the
probability of being in either a or b
so you could write that as a probability
of a union b
uh equals the probability of a plus the
probability of b
now i'm saying here the word probability
because that's what we're going to put
this to use
for but this is just math okay we don't
have any interpretation necessarily that
we attach to what this is this will work
for probability but mathematicians just
think well yeah this is a measure
that i can define on a set and it has
certain formal properties and i can
manipulate it okay
so at that level there's a lot you can
do just from these very simple axioms
i'm not going to do anything complicated
here but i'm going to do some lingo
that we might find useful later so you
can define the joint probability one of
the things uh
about this whole subject of probability
and statistics
is that it is so useful that many
different subfields use it right
obviously physicists use probability all
the time pure mathematicians use it
applied statisticians use it
other kinds of scientists use it
information theory computer science they
all use it
and they all have developed slightly
different notations for doing so so
the probability notation that you might
be most familiar with depending on what
you've seen might be a little bit
different than
what someone else uses so i gotta i've
got to use what i'm used to
using uh you'll go along with me right
so the joint probability
is what in my field we write as a comma
b
and this is basically the probability of
being of an event
uh being in both a and b so when you
write
um yeah when you write p of a that's the
the probability that the event that you
randomly choose
from the universe happens to be an a
when you write p
a comma b that's the probability that
when you randomly choose an event it is
in both a
and b so it's in that intersection right
there right so the probability of being
an a and b
is equal to the probability of being the
intersection of a
and b that's what we call the joint
probability
and there's also something we can call
the conditional probability
the conditional probability is written p
oops p a
bar b and you can read this off as
either the conditional probability of a
given b
or just the probability of a given b
it's the probability that if you know
the element the random event is in the
subset b
what's the probability it's also in a
okay
so that's just the probability that the
event is in both a
and b so that's the joint probability we
already just mentioned
divided by the probabilities in b to
start with
so this is saying given that you know
you're in b
what is the probability you're also in a
okay so
it's the probability that you happen to
be in both of them
full stop divided by the probability
we're in b in the first place
and so this is very very useful when you
do inference when you do statistical
inferences saying oh i know one thing is
true what's the probability some
something else is also going to be true
if you're playing poker you're playing
texas hold'em and you have two cards in
your hand
you have one ace you might want to say
all right there's six other people at
the table
what is the probability that one of them
also has an ace or two aces or something
like that
given that you have an a's that's a
conditional probability so you can see
why gamblers are going to
be very interested in these uh this
formalization of probability okay
but that's so this is this is what you
need to do math of probability you can
you know define a whole bunch of more
things there's mutual informations and
entropies and things like that that you
can define for these probability
distributions
but then you can also ask okay given
that this is the mathematical
formalization
what is probability physically where
does it come from what does probability
mean and that's much dicier
it's not that we don't know the answer
well we don't know the answer
it's not that we don't have an answer
it's that we have more than one
possible answer and we're not people
don't agree on what the right answer is
probably you know as with often as is
often the case
it's not that there is a right answer
it's that in different circumstances
different answers
are appropriate okay people that's not
going to stop people from arguing
so there are two notions of probability
that i get a lot of play and maybe this
is the exhaustive set like i'm not an
expert in the philosophy of probability
so i'm trying
i'm trying to give you the very basics
here not the comprehensive once and for
all viewpoint
there's something that you might call
objective probability
and objective probabilities are
sometimes called
chances
or propensities
these are not exactly the same thing but
i'm not going to tell you what the
subtle differences are between them i'm
just letting you know
the vocabulary words so if you if you
thought for example that
uh in quantum mechanics the probability
that a uranium atom will decay in a
certain time
okay that's if you could easily imagine
i'm not going to say
again what's right or wrong but you
could imagine it being the case that
that's just an objective fact about the
world
right given a certain time scale given a
certain isotope of uranium
what is the probability the nucleus will
decay that's just a fact about the world
okay it's not up to you it has nothing
to do with what you know and what you
don't know it's just a fact so
that viewpoint would go so we call that
the chance
uh that this is going to happen and
there's a view of probability that
things have a propensity
for happening and therefore they get
this objective probability out of that
not going to go into those details but
these are the words that are attached to
that
and this point of view that
probabilities are objective things about
the world
goes hand in hand with something called
frequentism
and frequentism is the idea that you
should define a probability by imagining
you can do
something an infinite number of times so
when someone says what do you
mean when you tell me that the chance
that the coin flip is going to give me
heads
is 50 a frequentist would say well what
that means is
if i flipped the coin an infinite number
of times
i would get 50 50 heads and tails that's
what it means to say the probability
and furthermore i mean there'd be a
footnote there saying and there's
nothing
else i can tell you about this structure
you know it's not that
uh the coin flips a different it's not
that it gets
tails every time heads was the last one
like it alternates heads tails heads
tails heads tails that's not quite what
they have in mind
because then there's something extra you
could say that would give you additional
information if all you can say is that
if you flip the coin infinite number of
times you get 50 50 heads and tails
that's when you would say there's an
objective probability
of getting of heads being point five or
fifty percent right
okay so that's an idea um there are
obviously advantages to this idea this
notion of probability any anytime
something can be objective that's
good right we like it when it's
subjective the opposite of objective
is subjective or you know the
contrasting idea
and subjective means relative to a
person
right you know a subjective thing the
subject to the self
the i right gets all very philosophical
so um
objective is just out there in the world
everyone agrees subjective is somehow
more
personal and it's nice when things are
objective i mean that makes them sound
like it's science it's not just my
feelings that are involved right
um but on the other hand the idea that
you define
probability by imagining you're able to
do something an infinite number of times
can be a little bit impractical right
like you never actually do anything
an infinite number of times and some
things you know perfectly well
are only going to happen once like in my
book something deeply hidden when i talk
about quantum mechanics i talk a little
bit about subjective versus objective
probabilities
and i use the example of the 2020 nba
championship
and i say that there is a probability
that the philadelphia 76ers are going to
win the 2020 nba championship
now that only happens once right uh but
we talk about the probability we
bet on it you know you can gamble on
probabilities like that now
ironically i didn't know at the time
there was a chance that nobody would win
the 2020 nba championship because of
quarantine
it looks like it is going to happen as
of as of this uh recording that i'm
doing right now
but still the point being that there are
things that clearly are subjective and
yet we use
probability talk about and for that
matter we couldn't even imagine what it
would mean
to be a frequentist about something like
that if you think it's
possible to talk about probabilities of
one-time events like the 2020 nba
championship
um you clearly can't mean the frequency
of it happening an infinite number of
times because you can't do that
experiment in
number times the basketball players
would get older you'd not be doing the
same nba championship over and over
again
okay so you mean something else when you
say the probability of that event in the
future is a certain amount
and what you mean is typically taken to
be the credence
i don't know so i started thinking in
the middle of writing there once again
always a bad idea
credences to be plural just like there
that's your subjective degree of belief
right the degree that you know the
amount you'd be willing to bet that
something was going to happen
and this you know just to drive home
that it's not just uh a frequency
you can have credences about events that
already happened
right what is the credence that uh only
one shooter shot jfk
right people disagree about whether or
not that's true there is an answer i
mean you think there's only one answer
to it but if you don't
know it if you have some ignorance then
you attach a credence you say well i
think there's a certain probability that
that was the case a certain probability
uh that it didn't happen so this comes
from
ignorance and not ignorance in you know
a pejorative sense there's something you
should know and don't something you just
don't know
like many things about the world you
don't know no no person is laplace's
demon who knows everything
so we talk about probabilities in these
two
different ways and you might want to
know well which is right or which which
should we use and i think the answer is
you know
i'm not sure what the answer is let me
put it this way i think it's absolutely
necessary
to use subjective credence-like
probabilities in some cases like i just
said
you know for the nba championship or for
kennedy's assassination or whatever
it makes perfect sense to talk in the
language of
probability and it's clearly not a
frequency it's clearly not even
objective people can disagree
i'm less clear about whether there's
anything in
physics or in science that uh can
really be called an objective
probability but maybe there is you could
certainly imagine a world in which it is
you know we talked earlier about the grw
theory of quantum mechanics
right the objective collapse model when
there's a probability per unit time at
the wave function of the electron
just localizes onto some point if
that theory is right there is some
objective
chanciness to the universe and then
you'll be very clear that you could use
that kind of frequentist approach
to define what you mean by probability
what we can do
is if you think that there are objective
frequencies you can also admit there are
sometimes subjective
objective probabilities there are also
sometimes subjective probabilities
credences
and then you can talk about trying to
relate the two of them to each other
so david lewis who's a famous
philosopher uh
he's extremely famous among other
philosophers he's less famous among the
general public
but he invented what is called the
principle principle
and i know that the name is a joke that
was intense attentional
but he he called it that so principle
principle oh he's a 50 50 probability
that we'll
get the right spelling first and later
principle
so the most important principle right
and the principal principle the jokey
name uh
says that when there are i'm not gonna
write the whole thing down when there
are objective chancey kinds of
probabilities in the world
and you have subjective credences that
you're going to assign to these
different outcomes
you should align your credences to the
objective chances that's what the
principle principle says
your credences are personal they're
subjective you can pick them you can say
i don't believe that this is true
but lewis is saying when there are
objective facts
about the frequency of something
happening you better if you're smart as
a normative guideline you better align
your credences
to the chances whatever they may be
so this is again a philosophical can of
worms seems very
useful but um i'm not going to go into
the details i just want to let you know
that you can live in a world where you
believe in both
objective probabilities and subjective
ones and they can happily play along
under the right circumstances
okay that was both a little bit of the
math background
what probability is how we talk about it
a little bit of the philosophy
background
uh what it means now we can put it to
work in physics
okay that's what we're really here for
so in physics
where probability really came into the
game was in the 19th century you know
the 19th century is underrated
in the history of physics you know we
talk about um
you know ancient physics with aristotle
and we talk about galileo and newton
and sometimes if you give a very quick
history of physics you tend to skip from
galileo newton right to einstein and
quantum mechanics
um but then in the you know the 1800s
19th century was just
chock full of cool stuff with
statistical mechanics which you can talk
about here
electromagnetism you know the precursors
to special relativity
atomic theory lots of cool stuff so
we're going to think about
statistical mechanics in a very
simple-minded way that is to say let's
think about a box of gas
this is the standard example that we all
like to use let me see if my
pen will do this make a square there we
go that's a box
make a little bit more square and then
we're going to fill it with gas
and we know because we are modern
physicists and we've had the last
couple of biggest ideas videos we know
that there are really atoms
in the box of gas but we also know that
none of us knows exactly
the positions and velocities of all the
atoms so we talk about the atoms as
a gas instead with certain coarse
macroscopic
properties so how do we relate the fact
that we think that
really there is a single description
of the positions and velocities of all
the molecules to the fact that we don't
know what that is and we still hope to
do some useful physics
with it okay so let's define a few
notions here
so we have the phase space for a single
particle
right which we would call one particle
phase space
that's the information you need to give
me to
say what's going to happen to one
particle if you knew what was happening
to all the other ones you need to give
me the position of velocity of this
particle and then all the forces acting
on it
um so that is the position
and the velocity of that particle
remember when we talk about phase space
we can move back and forth from velocity
to momentum
this is all not relativistic so we're
just doing newtonian mechanics momentum
is
m times the velocity so they're
interchangeable and
this is six dimensional
okay three velocities three positions
we're in a three-dimensional space
i've only drawn a two-dimensional box
but you know what i mean and this is
called
for reasons which will become only
slightly more clear in a second
mu space
so we have a lot of particles in the box
but for any one of them
its phase space is a six dimensional
space and we call that mu space
we could also talk about the phase space
of the entire system
right so that also has a phase space
every physical system
has a phase space that describes it so
if you have n particles
the n particle phase space
is a whole set of things right x1
v1 for particle one comma
x2 v2 particle two
and then maybe a lot of them uh you
could have avogadro's number 10 to the
23 or many many more particles than that
um and this is six n
dimensional because there's six
dimensions for each
particle uh it's phase space and this is
called
gamma space
so i actually do not know why mu and
gamma are the two letters that are used
for these two different ideas
but at least it's clear you need two
different letters because these are two
different
things right um the phase space for the
whole thing is gamma space the phase
space for just any one particle of time
is mu space and the reason why we're
distinguishing between these is because
you might think
that the sensible thing to do is to go
into gamma space
the phase space for the entire system
and have some probability distribution
on that space and see you know
ask what you can do with the physics of
that probability distribution
and it's true you might want to do that
but it turns out to be hard so actually
people work in mu space
which is much simpler because it's only
six dimensional so
one point
in gamma is the same as
n points
in mu so in other words you can think of
the phase space description of this
n particle system as a single point in a
big 6n dimensional space
or as a cloud of n points all living in
the six dimensional space that is
completely mathematically equivalent
okay
uh it's all about what is more
convenient for the problem that you're
going to do
so then you say okay well i have an
actual box of gas let's do the following
weird thought experiment
uh someone comes into your room where
you're sitting and they hand you a box
and they say there are n particles in
the box
maybe they you can even weigh the box
and you can say okay i know exactly how
much energy is in the box
but that's all you know okay you know
the total energy in the box you tell the
total number of particles
remember the the energy per particle
oops
the energies are just going to be the
kinetic energy
this is particle i is one half
and let's imagine they're just for
simplicity particles of equal mass okay
so they're hydrogen atoms or something
like that
one half m v i squared just the kinetic
energy so we're ignoring the
gravitational potential energy or
ignoring interactions maybe the
particles can bump into each other but
they don't
have long range forces acting on them so
there's no potential energy or anything
like that
and if you imagine that okay that's all
you know is it this amount of energy in
a certain number of particles
maybe so what could you do you could
maybe say
well i could be indifferent so there's
another principle
called the principle of indifference
which is one of those things where
in different circumstances we'll have
different different definitions etc
but basically it says when you have a
bunch of possibilities
and there's sort of a symmetry between
them okay there's no nothing special
that says some possibilities are
different than others then you assign
them equal probability
that's the principle of indifference
equal probability
to similar circumstances
so for example you could imagine
describing
the box of gas in gamma space by one
point in gamma space
now some of these points will have
different energies than others because
the velocities are different so there's
some
sub manifold of gamma space of constant
energy
where you know the total energy this is
per particle
e i e total
is the sum over i of one half
m v i squared so if you think about it
if you fix e total in velocity space
this is a sum of squares so you're
saying the sum of squares equals a
constant which is
picking out a sphere there's a spherical
region
the the surface of a sphere in velocity
space
so on that sphere on that
submanifold of fixed total energy the
principle of indifference would say
give me equal probability to be in
any state any positions any velocities
that are compatible with that total
energy
give that equal probability and
sometimes people do this this is called
the micro canonical ensemble
i i never remember what the names of
various ensembles are
but that's one thing that you can do and
you can make progress that way
but it's a weird thing in in some sense
i mean
who is this person who walked into your
room handing you a box of gas
and how do you know they aren't tricking
you right like how do you know
what they did to prepare the gas in the
box
like they could easily make it so that
all the molecules are moving to the left
right and they hit the wall and they all
move to the right uh that would not at
all be
compatible with the principle of
indifference that's a very very specific
kind of thing so the principle of
difference you know it has a long
complicated history i think laplace was
one of the people who talked about it
i'm not sure he actually
completely advocated it although he
often gets credit for saying
the principle of indifference um but you
know it's a
sensible thing to do probably if you
don't know any better but maybe
sometimes we know
better so there is something that there
is a situation in which we can
do a little bit better and that is
uh let's instead of this
instead of someone just handing you a
box let's imagine we have a box but it's
a real
it's a slightly more real world box in
that
the edges of the box are relatively thin
and the box is sitting in a room with
some temperature
in other words there can be a little bit
of exchange of energy
between the box and the room so
particles cannot leave the box
they're stuck in the box the number of
particles is fixed but
there are air molecules outside that are
bumping into the sides of the box
and the particles inside the box are
also bumping into the edges
so there can be slight variations in
energy energy exchanging between inside
and outside
so we imagine that the box is basically
embedded
in a heat bath
you don't maybe sometimes think of the
air in your room as a heat bath but
that's what it is
so again box of gas particles and
outside
there's stuff at temperature t
that can gradually interact with what's
going on inside the box
so what's going on inside the box is not
completely a closed system it can
exchange energy a little bit but the
number of particles
is fixed then you you're not looking
inside you're not seeing what's going on
inside the box
okay so that's how we're going to
physically change the situation a little
bit we're also going to change
mathematically how we deal with it a
little bit because
this gamma space thing this uh six n
dimensional phase space is just
too big so rather than working with a
probability distribution
in the n dimensional and six
n dimensional gamma space the n particle
phase space
we will work with what's called a
distribution function
in mu space in the one particle phase
space
so this is a bad name distribution
function
because different subfields use the same
terminology i mean very different things
but this is how physicists use it the
distribution function
f as a function of x and v so it's a
function
in mu space so just in the one particle
phase space
and what it tells you is the density of
particles
on average in that region of phase space
so remember in mu space you can think of
the whole collection as a cloud of n
particles and n is really big you know
10 to the 23 or bigger than that
so it's almost like a smooth cloud right
it's really a discrete set of points but
you can approximate it and this is what
you're doing here
as a smooth function in phase space so
if you really simplify your life by
looking just at two dimensions here
x and v then you have some point
some little tiny region in phase space
and f of x and v
is the average number
of particles in that region
so but it's important that it's in phase
space not in space so f
is not the density of particles in
physical space in a little cubic
centimeter
it's the density particles in phase
space so both particles at that
point at that location with that this
velocity a velocity in a certain
direction okay
now this is throwing away some
information already right um
there might be correlations or
relationships between the particles even
if they're
at similar points in phase space that
this formalism does not keep track of
still that's what we do this this goes
back to uh people like maxwell and
thompson and boltzmann and stuff like
that in the 1800s
they decided to simplify their lives by
working in the one particle phase space
instead of the n particle phase space
and i should say that
uh just to normalize things this is not
really a probability we told you that
when you add up all the probabilities of
everything you always get one
this is a number of distribution
function
so it's related to the total number of
particles by saying that the integral
of f which is a function of x and v
over d3x d3v
is not one but the number of particles
so this you can have a lot of particles
in some little region of phase space
less in some other region and then what
what you're able to show what you're
able to do physically remember we've
embedded our box in the heat bath so you
say what happens
and what happens is physically the gas
will approach an
equilibrium distribution
and the equilibrium distribution we
actually know what it looks like it's
named after maxwell and boltzmann
be embarrassing to uh misspell boltzmann
maxwell boltzmann distribution
so this is an astonishing wonderful fact
about statistical mechanics this is you
know
precursor to all the talk about uh
second law of thermodynamics which we'll
eventually get into in a later video
but this simple arrangement where
someone gives you a box of gas it
doesn't matter how they arranged it
doesn't matter how they started you let
a little bit of heat exchange happen
across the boundaries of the box
and what happens is that no matter what
the initial conditions were
the probability distribution
distribution function sorry
inside the box approaches a maxwell
boltzmann distribution i'm going to tell
you what that is
what is it so the maxwell-boltzmann
distribution is a particular form
of the distribution function f of x and
v so it's going to be some
function of of x and v the positions and
the velocities
and what function is going to be well
remember we're ignoring gravity
right so it's not like there's more
density near the bottom of the box than
up up there in the box the what this
means effectively is the random motions
the temperature
are more important than the fact that
gravity wants to pull things down okay
so what that means is that the
maxwell-boltzmann distribution
is going to be smooth it's going to be
invariant under
what is the word that i wrote down
spatially uniform that's what it's going
to be
there's no reason to have it be more
probable to find a particle over here
than over
there right it's gonna be the same
probability at every point in space
so what that means is that f of x
and v is actually just a function of
v it's not a function of x at all okay
there's no difference in probability
from one point to the
other it's also rotationally invariant
or isotropic if you want to say that
so we have a function that is just a
function of velocity but velocity is a
vector it has a direction as well as a
magnitude
and what this is saying is that there's
no preferred direction in the box
you know the shape of the box whether
it's really a cube or anything like that
doesn't really matter
particles are all bumping into each
other and they're bumping into the sides
and what that means is that this
function of v is actually just a
function of the magnitude of v
v equals the magnitude it's the same
in every direction okay finally okay so
there's some function
of v that is the maxwell-boltzmann
distribution and i'm just going to tell
you what it is
f of v well there's some pre-factors i'm
going to ignore so it's proportional to
v squared times e to the minus
one-half mv squared which you'll
recognize is the energy
of that particular configuration uh of
that particular particle
divided by kt where t is temperature
remember we've embedded our box in a
heat bath with temperature t
and k is a constant of nature called
boltzmann's constant
i'm not gonna tell you what that is
either because
we set it equal to one and just like h
bar and c uh
we will end up setting k boltzmann's
constant equal to one
we'll try to remember it okay so what
this is telling us
is that if we plot this very specific
functional form here's
f and here's uh v well there's two
things going on
one thing is that there is a v squared
so that's a parabola it looks like this
the other is there's e to the minus v
squared roughly speaking so one half mv
squared is the kinetic energy of a
single particle
and it exponentially decreases as that
energy goes up
so if i plot minus e to the minus sorry
e to the minus 1 fmv squared on this
plot it looks like this
and i multiply these two things together
to get the maxwell boltzmann
distribution
and it looks like this it goes up as a
peak
then it's going to go down again
so this is the maxwell boltzmann
distribution
it has a peak some particular velocity
and what it's saying is that
you can find uh individual this is
saying what is the density
of number of particles in phase space
right so what is the number of particles
with this particular velocity
what's the number of particles with zero
velocity well it's small
okay it approaches zero as you go to
zero velocity but only because there's
only one way to have zero velocity
there's a lot of ways to have a little
velocity
and if you're if you're thinking about
small velocities
much much smaller than kt then the e to
the minus one
half mv squared doesn't matter it's
almost a constant it's
approximately constant compared to the v
squared which is growing
and what it's basically saying is that
there's just more ways to have a large
velocity
than a small velocity if the energies
are not that different from each other
okay
that's where the v squared comes from
remember the we said
up here constant energy
is like a sphere in velocity space so
the reason why it's
v squared is because the area of that
sphere goes like v squared
right areas go like distance squared
but then what this is saying is that
given that you're
exchanging energy with your environment
probably
the typical energy of a particle in the
box is going to be the same as the
temperature
outside and it's possible
for a particle inside the box to have a
much larger energy than that
but it becomes really really unlikely it
becomes exponentially unlikely this is e
to the minus the kinetic energy
in units of kt and units of the
temperature outside
so that's the maxwell-boltzmann
distribution and it's an
amazing fact of physics that a box of
gas embedded in a heat bath
approaches this distribution and this
idea of embedding in the heat bath like
this
if this is the micro canonical ensemble
which says
completely equal probability given a
fixed energy
here the energy is not fixed right
because it's exchanging energy with the
environment
and you get what is just called the
canonical ensemble
the temperature is kind of like the
average energy but there are
fluctuations
around that okay so this is the the what
you reach in the canonical ensemble
and why how do you derive this well
there's different ways to derive this
fact one way
is this is the maximum entropy
configuration that the gas can go into
given that it's going to be at this
temperature okay given the other number
of particles
and there's going to be a temperature is
going to reach this is the maximum
entropy configuration so the entropy
we're not going to go into this
in detail right now but the entropy is
something you can also define
given this distribution function there's
a formula for it
and the formula is s equals minus
the integral of f as a function of x and
v i'm not going to
draw the little vector signs here times
the log
of f of x and v
d3x d3v okay
i think i told you about logarithms
before right so if you have
the e to the logarithm
of x is equal to x or likewise
the logarithm of e to the x
equals x that's what this that's the
logarithm means so this formula
minus the integral of f log f that's the
entropy that's one of the ways in which
you could talk about entropy
you could also describe it in terms of
mu
gamma space this is mu space that we're
in right now but this is a nice little
thing that you can define
it's a finite number boltzmann showed i
think it was boltzmann who showed i
think maxwell
guessed or argued his way into the form
of the maxwell boltzmann distribution
and then boltzmann did some more
rigorous investigation of it but it
maximizes the entropy
and as we'll talk about later that's a
way of saying that
given the constraints given the fact
that there's a certain number of
particles given the fact that the
temperature is a certain value and the
temperature is the average
kinetic energy etc most of
the allowed phase space is in this
maximum entropy
situation that's why you tend to go to
the maximum boltzmann distribution
because most
particles will look like that under this
condition
so this is a wonderful example of
statistical mechanics the idea that
really it's not this is absolutely an
example of the subjective probability in
action okay
because we all think that in that box of
gas
well sorry we all would have thought in
the 1800s
when maximum bolts when we're talking
about this that there were atoms or
there were molecules and they had
some particular positions and velocities
but we don't know
what they are and so we can assign
credences we can assign probabilities to
the different possible ways you could
configure
the points in phase space and maxwell
boltzmann say well this is the
particular distribution
that we should end up getting by
maximizing the entropy and it's that
kind of thinking
that helped them invent this whole field
of statistical mechanics again maxwell
boltzmann also gibbs thompson aka lord
kelvin
and their friends you know set up this
whole formalism of statistical mechanics
and it's amazing so what it's telling
you is that you can do physics
you can learn things you know we learned
something we said what happened to a box
of gas
that's a very physical tangible
measurable observable thing
even without knowing everything there is
to know so
this is crucially important to
mapping this microscopic physics whether
it's deterministic or not
onto the macroscopic world can you still
say something about the macroscopic
world even if you don't know
everything about the microscopic
goings-on and this is the first
indication that yes you can
uh and you can sort of quantify your
ignorance and nevertheless say
interesting things and so statistical
it was it was very um controversial
at the time you know uh back in germany
people were very slow to catch
on to statistical mechanics and
boltzmann in particular got a lot of
flack
from a lot of people uh because he was
in germany like the the
british caught on to it pretty quickly
so maxwell and thompson
were fine uh they were celebrated and
boltzmann had fun with them but then
when he went back to germany he got a
lot of
uh flack because a lot of people in
germany led by ernst mock of mock's
principal fame
didn't want to believe in the existence
of atoms okay
they thought that things like the second
law of thermodynamics were not
probabilistic
laws that you get from averaging over
lots of atoms that they thought there
was some
law of nature that said entropy
increased so but the statistical point
of view won out in the end and it's a
wonderful example of the use of
probability
in physics so that was the
19th century okay so the lesson is we
can use notions of probability
because we're ignorant because there's
something we don't know about the system
then the 20th century comes along okay
and we have quantum mechanics
and that seems to be a whole other
kettle of fish
as you know by now quantum mechanics
tells us that when we measure
an observable feature of a quantum
system you cannot predict what outcome
you're going to get with perfect
certainty
the best you can do is to predict a
probability or to state a probability of
getting different experimental outcomes
that seems different
you have the born rule
that the probability of getting some
outcome
x is the wave function that we
associated with x
magnitude squared and it seems certainly
in the
well i almost said certainly in the
copenhagen interpretation but the phrase
certainly in the copenhagen
interpretation should almost never be
used because the copenhagen
interpretation is not very well defined
but
certainly in the minds of many people
this kind of
probability which you'll notice does fit
all of kolmogorov's axioms there okay it
fits very well
as long as the set of events that you're
allowed to look at are compatible with
each other so you cannot observe
position and velocity at the same time
but if you look at the probability for
all the positions of an electron for
example they would satisfy
kamal grove's axioms by the way again
parenthetically what you could do
rather than what i just did which is to
brush under the rug the fact that you
shouldn't
think of observing position and
observing velocities or momentum
at the same time when you talk about the
probability in quantum mechanics
you can instead try to to develop a
quantum mechanical theory of probability
which is different than kamalguard's
theory of probability and that's another
way
you can go but as long as you just pay
careful attention to what you're allowed
to observe at any one time
ordinary probability works perfectly
well okay
um but it seems like an objective
feature of the world
so this is supposed to be the point
of something like bell's theorem right
uh the difficulty
of finding hidden variables at least
local hidden variables
is that the reason why there's only a
probability we can attach to different
outcomes
isn't because there's something some
fact some values of some parameters that
we just don't know
it's because they are intrinsically
unpredictable okay
but then other people you know bone will
come along and say
well i can invent a theory that says
that there are hidden variables and ever
it comes along says something completely
different so
it's subtle and actually the answer is
in quantum mechanics given that we don't
know the one and true once and for all
true theory of quantum mechanics
that means we don't know what
probability comes from
in quantum mechanics yet uh different
schools of thought think they know but
they don't agree with each other
so so let's contrast three popular
approaches
to pump to probability in quantum
mechanics
and these are just the three approaches
to quantum mechanics that we talked
about before
so one would be hidden variables
so the hidden variable theories like
bones
say that in addition to the wave
function there are
some other variables like positions of
particles and you don't know what they
are
and in fact there's an argument that
they should be distributed
according to some equilibrium
distribution
and you can sort of argue about that
argument but that's that's a big part of
being a good bohmian and then you use
that equilibrium distribution to derive
that you get the born rule for
actual experiments so in hidden variable
theories
you have psi plus let's say
particle positions
both the wave functions and these extra
variables and these particle positions
are unknown
so it is exactly like statistical
mechanics it's
perfectly deterministic
there are equations for how psi evolves
and for how the particles evolve so
let's make that very clear the
schrodinger equation h
psi equals i d
psi dt okay this equation
is 100 deterministic
it is more deterministic than newton's
laws remember that was the point of
telling you about norton's dome
f equals m a looks deterministic but
there are these sneaky little
uh exceptions to that the schrodinger
equation is linear
which is a way of saying that on both
sides of the schrodinger equation
psi the wave function appears exactly
once it's not psi
squared or e to the psi or anything like
that so the kinds of sneaky
set of measures zero non-deterministic
behavior that exist in newton's laws
are not anywhere to be found in the
schrodinger equation given the
schrodinger equation it is true
that i can evolve it forward and
backward in time
the reason why we get the bourne rules
of course because quantum measurements
don't obey the schrodinger equation
something else seems to be going on
and in hidden variable theories in
addition to the schrodinger equation you
also have a guidance equation
that's why hidden variable theories are
sometimes called pilot wave theories
you can think about the wave function as
a wave that pushes around
the particles but the guidance equation
is also completely deterministic
the indeterminism comes in because you
don't know
the positions of the particles just like
in statistical mechanics
so this is an example of subjective
probability
so oops that was terrible oh my goodness
subject
div probability
because you don't know the state of the
system there you go
but in contrast with that like i already
mentioned you have grw
slash objective collapse models
which just say as part of the
postulates of the theory there's a
certain probability per unit time
that the wave function is going to
collapse okay that's what objective
collapse means
[Music]
the original grw theory is just truly
random in that sense there's other
theories like pen roses where the
collapses are
triggered by something some physical
event makes collapse happen
but what the collapse is actually to is
still completely random
so these theories are objectively
probabilistic
so these theories in other words there's
an objective chanciness
stochasticity randomness to the world
it's a very very different kind of
probability than
appears in the hidden variable theories
and then guess what we have everett
slash many worlds
the tension mounts which is it going to
be is it going to be objective
probability or subjective probability
so of course ever it's got to be
difficult
it's got to be a little bit slightly
more complicated
in everett as you know the only equation
is the schrodinger equation right that's
the fundamental equation i just told you
the schrodinger equation is 100
deterministic
so the fundamental dynamics of the wave
function of the universe
in everetti in many worlds quantum
mechanics is just deterministic
full stop but as you also know because
we also talked about it
probabilities nevertheless arise and
they arise from what we called
self-locating uncertainty so imagine
that you are on a branch of the wave
function here
and you have some spin and it's in a
superposition of spin up and spin down
and then you measure the spin or let's
say the spin gets measured doesn't need
to be you who does the measuring
and so there's a branch where the spin
is up and a branch where the spin is
down
and that's going to happen faster than
you know about it
okay so the branching happens really
really really fast
so there's a moment when there are two
branches and you don't know
which branch you are on okay that's
self-locating uncertainty
sometimes called indexical uncertainty
because you'd imagine a little index
that says i am on this branch
but you don't know what the index is
okay and
so this is subjective
uncertainty it's something that you
don't know
but it's a different kind of thing that
you don't know okay in
up here in the um oops where'd it go i
lost my little
uh well that's too bad i lost my little
highlighter i don't know what happened
but anyway up here where we were in the
hidden variable world
okay there was something we didn't know
and the thing we didn't know
was the state of the world right we
didn't know what the positions of the
particles were which is part of the
specification of the state
in everett you can know the state of the
world exactly
but there's still something you don't
know which is where you are in it
so that's a different kind of subjective
uncertainty
you need to attach credences that's
something you need to do
but how to attach those cretans as
credences is a little bit
less obvious okay and i would argue
i have argued other people have argued
that there is a clearly right
rational sensible way to attach those
credences and that is to use
the born rule the probability of being
on any branch is the wave function
squared
but other people don't quite agree with
that you know they haven't yet seen the
light yet
but what's interesting to me is that um
these different these you know
pre-existing philosophical debates
about the nature of probability and what
it means are
not only not resolved but every possible
option
could be true given what we know about
quantum mechanics if someone says you
know
is the world fundamentally deterministic
we don't know
we don't know the answer to that in grw
it's not
in hidden variable theories and everett
it is there's other theories of quantum
mechanics
obviously so we don't know whether the
world is fundamentally deterministic or
not
if it is how do probabilities arise
in a deterministic world we don't know
that either
in hidden variable theories they arise
because there's something we don't know
about the world
in ever they arise because there's
something we don't know about where we
are
in the world so it's interesting that
you know none of this is yet settled
again i like i like to point out
open problems for the youngsters in the
audience to solve for their phd theses
this is a good set of problems here you
know the relationship of probability and
quantum mechanics
subjective and objective probabilities
and so forth
i should say also um remember i said
before
i'm not even sure there are any
objective probabilities in the world
um so that's that goes along with me
being
an averredian this is saying that the
probabilities that arise in quantum
mechanics are subjective
just as much as the probabilities that
arise in uh
statistical mechanics are and david
lewis
actually went even further than this you
know david lewis the same guy with the
principle principle
his most famous thing is to talk about
possible worlds
so he wasn't he thought in he understood
you know about everybody in quantum
mechanics and so forth but that was not
his main focus
but he talked about the space of all
conceivable he said possible i should
say possible all possible worlds so
there's a by by world he doesn't mean a
branch of the everyday wave function he
means
a set of laws of physics being
instantiated in some universe
some reality okay so he's thinking of
really different realities
uh i talked about this a little bit in
podcast land in mindscape podcast
i had one podcast with ned hall
philosopher and another one with max
tegmark a cosmologist and we both talk
about this
idea of the set of all possible worlds
okay so lewis thought that all
like there's a possible world which is
newtonian mechanics there's a possible
world where
space is two-dimensional there's all
these different possible worlds an
infinite number of them
and lewis thought about you know how we
should think about these possible worlds
and he actually thought they were all
real
he advocated thinking of every possible
world as really existing
you don't need to go that far uh modal
realism
it was called but you don't need to go
that far but but he does point out
that you know we can think of
all probabilities like let's say um
you know we don't know what the laws of
physics are we don't know what the dark
matter is
is the dark matter a weakly interacting
massive particle is it an axion is it
something else
okay different people will assign
probabilities
you know you have to like like don't say
you don't want to like if you're
if you're an honest rational person
you should have credences for things and
you know maybe your credence is it's
something else i don't know about
and maybe your credence is not very
specific but if you're a scientist a
cosmologist you
need to have credences you need to and
the reason why is because you choose
what to think about right you choose
what to work on how to spend
your life so uh if you think that it's
very probable that the dark matter is a
weakly interacting massive particle
then that means you have a high greens
that that's true if you think it's an
axion or black holes or neutrinos then
you think that the credences are
different
and so what lewis says
at least once he said this is that you
can think of all probabilities
including um like the probability uh
that the axion to the dark matter and so
forth
the probability that a head uh coin will
turn up heads or tails
the probability that you know a certain
radioactive atom will decay
can be thought of as self-locating
uncertainties
are self-locating uncertainties
in the space of possible worlds
so lewis says there's a possible world
in which axions are the dark matter
there's a possible world
in which weakly or acting massive
particles are the dark matter when you
say i think there's a 60
chance that weakly interacting massive
particles are the dark matter
you're putting a credence on your
self-locating uncertainty about which
possible
world you live in so this is a different
way of self-locating uncertainty to
arise in everyday in quantum mechanics
it arises because you don't know where
you are
in the actual world even though we say
many worlds it's still one big wave
function of the universe you just don't
know where you are in that wave function
lewis is saying you consider really
different possible disjoint worlds they
didn't arise from the same
world in the past through schrodinger
evolution or anything like that they're
truly different possibilities
and we don't know which one is true so
that's a kind of self-locating
uncertainty another way that
probabilities arise
i don't know if this is actually true
i'm very sympathetic to it i like it but
i don't understand it well enough to
really say that i advocate for it
but i'm thinking about it i think it's
something that we should take seriously
okay last thing i want to do in this
video is to talk about
how we decrease our uncertainty you know
how you know so we have this uncertainty
we have self-locating certainty for
example
anyway we have probabilities we have
different theories of what is the dark
matter
uh you know was there a big bang and
stuff like this different
probabilities you know what is the right
theory of quantum mechanics is it
uh pilot waves hidden variables jrw ever
many worlds we have different
probabilities for this
and what we're going to do is science
we're going to go out there and observe
things about the world and learn about
it and hopefully figure out which of our
probabilities are correct right
so we're going to increase certain
probabilities decrease others we're
going to change our credences
in different propositions by collecting
data
and this is the whole universe of
bayesian inference
honestly it's amazing i've gotten this
far in a video about probability and
randomness without mentioning bayes's
name once yet
so bayes's theorem is is literally a
theorem it's not something that can be
wrong it's just if you have
probabilities probabilities obey a
certain rule
in particular this is saying um the
probability how probability changes when
you collect more data
that's what baze's theorem says but you
have to distinguish between bayes's
theorem
and the whole bigger set of ideas called
bayesian inference so let's first get to
the theorem okay so imagine you have a
set
of mutually exclusive
propositions or let's call them theories
because this is very often used in the
context of scientists trying to decide
which theory is correct
but any mutually exclusive set of
propositions uh works
the coin will become heads the coin will
become tails those are two theories okay
so call them theories ti
one of them is the head will the coin is
heads the coin will be tails those are
two different theories
there's a prior in bayesian reasoning
probability
for every theory so this is p of ti
so this says even before you've looked
at the world before you've done any
science before you've done anything
before you collected any data
before you flipped the coin for example
uh
you need to already assign a probability
you can't just say no i don't know
i don't know what it is you need in
order to get along in the world you need
to be able to assign probabilities to
things
so you start with a prior probability
the coin has not yet been flipped
well i'm going to give it 50 50 heads or
tails those are my prior probabilities
and then i collect some data
and i'm going to call the data d so
maybe the data is
oh someone just gave me a receipt for
this person who's about to flip the coin
had purchased a trick coin at a magic
store that always turns out heads right
so that's going to change my
probabilities i got some new data in
there or
oh a weakly interacting massive particle
was just discovered at the xenon dark
matter detector or something like that
okay
data can come in in various sorts so
what we do
is we then define the likelihood
the likelihood of measuring that data
if each individual theory were true okay
so the likelihood
is a conditional probability the
likelihood is saying if this theory were
true if we conditionalize on that
particular theory
then what would the probability have
been that we would have collected
that particular piece of information we
would have located that data
so the likelihood is the probability of
collecting the data
given the theory okay what we want to
get
what we want to do is to update our
priors
with the fact that we've collected the
data so we want is the posterior
probability the probability that our
theory is true
now that we've collected the data so
this the likelihood is something we can
calculate
right our theory should make a
prediction that's what it means the
theory predicts that the coin will be
heads up 50 of the time or whatever um
different theories will make different
predictions
and then this is what we calculate so
this sorry this is what we infer so you
calculate this
you collect the data
you start with this
where do your priors come from yeah
don't ask me this is the big looming
question
in bayesian inference you know how do
you choose your priors in the first
place
how do you choose to think that weakly
interacting massive particles are more
likely than axions or whatever
lots of different things go into it you
know how pretty is it how elegant is the
theory how simple
uh have you written any papers on that
particular model
therefore you'd be happy you know this
is all stuff that could in principle go
into determining your
priors um and then you infer
from all that the after you've collected
the data what is your new probability
for that theory
and so baze's law is how to do that
baze's law says the probability of the
theory now that you've collected the
data
is equal to the probability the
likelihood the probability that
the oops that you would have collected
that data
under the theory times the prior
for that theory divided by the total
probability that the data would be
collected
in some theory okay so the total
probability of collecting the data
is just the sum over all theories
of the likelihood probably data in
theory i
times the prior probability of theory i
so you can see that the thing on the top
of baze's
law is the thing we're summing over to
get the bottom
so by construction the left hand side is
going to be a collection of numbers
between zero and one that when you add
them together they're going to give you
one
okay because when you add all the
probabilities together you're just
taking the same thing on the top and
bottom of this right hand side of the
equation
so this is guaranteed to give you a good
probability and this is every
statistician's and many scientists
favorite
rule and so this is again this is a law
this is a theorem
this is how probabilities fit together
but it also
suggests an attitude it's just a
mathematical expression but it also
suggests a philosophy of life
and the philosophy of life is there's a
whole bunch of things that we're
ignorant about i mean they may be true
they may not be true
but we should attach credences to them
we should attach priors we should say i
think this is probably true this thing
is less likely to be true etc
and then we should go through life
collecting data and updating
our priors using bayes's theorem just
like this
and the sad fact is that people don't do
this uh this is this is
you know as as uh someone said people
call this bayesian rationality but you
might as well just call it rationality
it's just
being rational about a world where you
are not sure
about things now in fact there's all
sorts of psychological
barriers to being a good bayesian
reasoner
there are examples where people are
given data that is
unlikely according to their favorite
theory and they get defensive about it
and become more and more wedded to their
favorite theory okay
it's not doesn't always happen that way
but it's definitely something that can
happen
it's hard to be a good bayesian reasoner
certainly if you're playing poker
you should be a good bayesian reasoner i
mean you might say well
i have two pair i think that's the best
hand i will raise
and someone re-raises you you should
update what is the chance that they
would re-raise me
well it's low if they have a crappy hand
and it's high if they have a really good
hand
so maybe i should lower the probability
that my hand is the best one
right you should be always doing
bayesian updating as you're sitting
there playing poker
but it's hard to do in practice let's
let's finish this up by running through
one example
of seeing how it actually works okay so
let's use
um it's just a modern physics thing that
we really care about
is you know what we're really annoyed by
is the fact that we didn't discover any
new particles of a large hadron collider
other than the higgs boson which we all
suspected was there
we haven't discovered super symmetry or
extra dimensions or any of the things we
were looking for so
let's use that as an example so here's
an example
let t one
be super symmetry exists
exists in nature so t1 the theory one is
that
the fundamental laws of physics whatever
they are have
supersymmetry as an aspect and t2
is that no they don't
supersymmetry is just a theorist's pipe
dream it is not part of the real laws of
nature okay
so imagine you're a physicist and you
like supersymmetry imagine your
physicist 20 years ago
we haven't yet turned on the large
hadron collider and you have priors
so you've thought about it you thought
about the mathematical elegance and the
explanatory power
and the unification prospects of
supersymmetry and you said this all
looks good to me
so you say my prior on t1 is 0.9
and therefore my prior on t2 because
these are mutually exclusive theories
and they're a comprehensive set there's
no third option supersymmetry exists or
it doesn't okay
so they better add up to one so i better
give 0.1
for my prior nothing this is just an
illustrative example you don't have to
agree with this particular physicist
okay we're just running the numbers
um and then your data is we
did not see supersymmetry
at the lhc we turned on large hadron
collider we did not see super symmetry
now the way to play the game is before
you turned on
the lac you should be clear about your
likelihoods
okay now the the problem so
what you want is the probability of
getting that data in theory one and the
probability of getting that data in
theory two
okay i could make this a little bit
better written
because p's look like these um
and in principle what i said up here was
you just calculate the likelihood i mean
if you have a well-posed theory
it should make a statement about what is
the probability of getting different
data
sadly in the real world you very often
face theories like these which are not
well posed
okay theory one is not a specific model
of
grand unification and symmetry breaking
in the whole bit
any specific model will make a
prediction
either probability one or probability
zero that supersymmetry is going to be
located at the lhc
but this is not like that the idea that
supersymmetry exists in
some model is a wide
variety of possible worlds right there's
a lot of different kinds of ways that
supersymmetry could exist
maybe it exists but it's broken at the
planck scale so it exists it's part of
nature but it's not visible at the large
hadron collider
maybe it exists but it's broken right
there at the electro weak scale in which
case you would expect it to observe it
at the large head rock glider
so a certain amount of judgment comes
into calculating these likelihoods
even though they're supposed to be
perfectly well defined so
it's a sad fact so let's say that what
you would
have guessed before we turn the large
hadron collider on
is that if supersymmetry exists
we probably would see it let's say you
thought there was an 80 chance
that you would see supersymmetry at the
lhc so the probability of not seeing it
the likelihood of not seeing it you
write as 0.2
okay and the likelihood of not seeing
supersymmetry if there is no
supersymmetry is one
these are likelihoods they don't need to
add to one okay they could be they could
both be one in different theories in
which case
if the likelihoods are the same in
different theories then basis theorem
does not move your
priors into different posteriors at all
but okay
then we calculate the probability of
getting that data
in the whole set of possible theories
right the probability of getting that
data you did not see
super symmetry is uh well the
probability of
getting that data in theory 1 which is
0.2
times the prior probability for theory 1
which is 0.9
plus the probability of getting that
data in theory 1
which is 1 times the prior probability
sorry
theory 2 which is 1 times the prior in
theory 2 which is 0.1
and i've done this ahead of time this is
0.28
you can check my math at home my prior
that my math is correct is about 50
um so that's the probability of getting
the data in given your
priors and your likelihoods and
therefore the probability
that theory one is true the probability
that supersymmetry is still lurking out
there to be found
given that you haven't found it at the
lhc this is kind of fun that we can
actually calculate this
uh it's uh
well what is the formula where is
bayes's law
the likelihood of that in theory one
times the prior for theory one
so that is 0.2 times 0.9
divided by the total probability of that
data 0.28
and i work this out and i get 0.64
okay so i started the day 20 years ago i
thought there was a 90
chance the supersymmetry was out there
somewhere lurking to be found as a part
of the fundamental laws of nature
i turned the lhc on i didn't see it i
was disappointed
but i'm still left with what i would
write as a 64
chance that supersymmetry is still out
there so on the one hand
less by a substantial amount than i
started with on the other hand
still greater than 50 percent this is
supposed to explain
why there's plenty of physicists out
there who think that it's still very
likely that supersymmetry is part of
nature either we'll find it soon or the
next big collider or we're not going to
find it because it's broken at the
planck scale
but it's still out there anyway this is
an example
of uh good bayesian reasoning the
the idea is a bayesian inference is that
this is the right way to think about all
probabilities
you should be honest about your priors
and this is why people start arguing
frequentist versus bayesians
frequentists really want probabilities
to be objective
okay they really want to imagine that i
could have flipped the coin an infinite
number of times and find the frequency
with which it came up heads or tails
bayesians say i should admit that
probabilities are just
not objective and i should admit that i
have priors which are subjective
and the frequentest say well your priors
could be anything you get any answer you
want
and the bayesians will say yes i could
by picking dumb priors but number one
real scientists don't pick dumb priors
like they might disagree
but they shouldn't be wildly
inconsistent and number two
we should be able to agree on the
likelihoods given those theories maybe
we can't but at least that's something
we should be able to do and so a good
bayesian
scientist when they write a paper with
some new data that points toward a
result
they will emphasize the likelihoods
rather than the priors or the posteriors
because those are more
subjective anyway it's a useful way to
help us think about quantitatively
how to locate ourselves in the set of
all possible worlds and it's a good way
of thinking about how probability
can be made compatible with the world
even if the fundamental laws of physics
are deterministic we don't know if they
are
i think that they probably are but
that's just my prior